hey guys I'm Ryan right Ryan right the
douche yep my dad Seibert we're gonna
check out today Lego Jurassic world game
P game pay gameplay trailer - we really
dug the first one they really felt like
a horror game for kids a horror game for
kids we went to a Jurassic world with
the drastic parts kind of scary
it's got cartoon violence I'm scared oh
no I'm scared
typically
you orgasm that turned her head it's so
scared
the Natalie diets bacon-loving time
you're gonna be the dynasty that thing
out there that is no dinosaur
it's a ps4 exclusive Wow or at least
that what that last screen would imply
true I agree with these words Daniel
deep yep it's good [ __ ]
I want it it solidifies just how good
this [ __ ] really is [ __ ] this tube right
here
yeah absolutely dude we could get a
variety of different dinos as if we
weren't expecting that but then you also
get a plate as the dinosaur I don't know
why it was super excited about that of
course you would have eventually been
able to play as the dinosaur can you
kill people it's Lego so the worst you
can do is disassemble them I hope you
can murder people kind of like hatred
but you're a dinosaur that would be one
hell of an experience huh again what do
they mean by all new bacon dinos or
loving bacon what was it
well they feet don't they feed the
dinosaurs pig in the movie like the
first feed the velociraptors don't they
I think so there was a go there well
there was a goat for the t-rex right but
I don't remember if it was a goat for
the velociraptors well there's someone
right now commenting saying were [ __ ]
idiots and he's gonna have the correct
answer because he's gonna pause this
video go look for it on his DVD and then
he's gonna come back and call us you
[ __ ] idiots
and there was arrested video yeah watch
this part me was like I they were
totally right this comes out on the day
of Jurassic world so I'm thinking I'm
gonna have like an orgy of Jurassic Park
I think I'm gonna watch the first three
Jurassic Park movies go to watch
Jurassic world come back play in the
game of Jurassic world Lego and then
it's Veronica I gonna dress up like
dinosaurs and we're gonna you know die
no [ __ ] yeah baby I was really excited
about ninety percent of the time Dino
man we're gonna let my t-rex impression
here we go
mm what's that with that that's a raptor
oh right
this videos nothing nothing let's talk
about dinosaurs what's your favorite
dinosaur leave a comment down below
letting us know what your favorite
dinosaur is seeing gained in the
audience that's great man
I'm glad to hear that anyway guys thanks
for tuning in if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Dan's gaming
channel boo boo boo and then you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we could get a product placement for
stuff like Guinness in it we want
Guinness Guinness is great it gets you a
hammered fast and then you get to do
things when you're drunk you could you
know sleep with ugly woman but you think
they're pretty at the time or you could
just drink more Guinness you could piss
on a cop's car or Guinness you you could
drive drunk nothing bad it comes from
don't drink and drive
I mean I haven't heard one Horror Story
don't don't drink a drive the Dan if it
really don't be an idiot
don't let Rick you're drunk something
bad really happened it wouldn't be a
joking matter
like how everyone perceives it don't
drink you drive